hey youtubers is Charlie so there's been
a rumor that Ben Affleck would sit
around on the set of Batman vs Superman
in costume like actually wearing the
Batman costume reworking parts of the
script so I thought it was too funny to
not make a video about what does that
actually mean I know it sounds like
somebody wrote the sentence wrong like
maybe he got into costume and also
reworked the script but when you think
about it if you're gonna be in costume
all day it takes a long time to get into
any Batman suit so naturally if you're a
big star who's brought onto a project
who's also a director and gonna be
working on the future Batman films
you're gonna have a pass at the script
you might as well do it while you're
sitting around waiting for them to set
up your shot if you've never been on a
movie set sometimes scenes can take a
long time to film like on a really big
comic book movie like this it's not
uncommon for them to spend an entire day
just filming one scene that might only
end up being a minute or two of screen
time and what will happen sometimes is
is if a director doesn't use a whole
bunch of cameras at the same time to
film a scene from a bunch of different
angles the actors will have to perform a
scene one way with the cameras and all
the lights set up a certain way they'll
have to get it right it might take him a
couple tries then they'll stop and spend
a whole bunch of time setting the lights
and the cameras up for a whole different
angle and perform the exact same scene
again and sometimes there'll be six
different angles that they'll need to
get so nowadays because those high
quality film cameras are getting so
small it's not uncommon for a director
to use a whole bunch of cameras at the
same time so that they don't have to
blow an entire day for one minute of
screen time of actors talking it's a
little bit different depending on what
kind of shot they're setting up but
there just winds up being a whole lot of
downtime in the middle of the day like
you'll spend an hour working on a scene
then you might get it they'll have to
set up for a different scene and you'll
just have like an hour to kill so
instead of taking the costume off
because it might take a whole hour to
get out of the costume you just sit
around in your costume doing whatever it
is you feel like doing til they call you
back to said so it's not really that big
of a surprise to see Ben Affleck sitting
around waiting for them to set up four
different shots just working on the
script but he has that free time what
I'm really curious is as to which parts
of the script he rewrote the most I'm
guessing a lot of it has to do with
Batman's motivation like that scene
where he's talking to Alfred about going
after Superman if there's a 1% chance we
have to treat it as an absolute
certainty stuff that informs the way
Batman makes decisions in the movie like
why is it that he goes after soo
man then you have the lighter scenes
like when he's talking to Superman in
this scene here and they have that
moment where he's like we haven't had a
whole lot of luck with costumed freaks
in our city the dialogue might have been
different he might not have liked it so
normally on a big movie like this actors
don't do stuff like that they don't
rewrite their own dialogue but because
Warner Brothers asked Ben Affleck to
become Batman right after he won the
Oscar for Argo I'm guessing that part of
the deal was that he would be allowed to
take a pass at the script now the actual
people that wrote the movie were Zack
Snyder Chris Terrio who's Ben Affleck's
producing partner like they made Argo
together so Ben Affleck would have had
input on the script anyway just because
he was working with Chris Terrio and
Chris Terrio was writing the movie with
Zack Snyder and I think David Goyer
worked on part of it too but I would be
amazed at the original script you know
before they started shooting is anything
close to what the final script ended up
being because a lot of times they'll
rewrite stuff on the day then they'll
incorporate that into the final script
and then submit that to the WGA for
writing credits because in Hollywood
when you write a movie you get credit
for it there's a very specific way how
that happens so when we say final script
is the final script based on the last
cut of the movie so like if there's a
deleted scene in the movie they'll take
that out of the final script before they
submit it the same thing happened with
Star Wars The Force awakens
there's deleted scenes on the DVD but if
you went and read the script a copy of
the script at the writers guild
it would look completely different
really I think the end result of Ben
Affleck reworking the script even doing
it on the day is just to make it more
real make the Batman character more real
may you feel less like a cardboard
action figure that you just pull off the
shelf and more like an actual human
being that just happens to be in a
superhero movie and then on top of that
you also have to consider that while
they were working on Batman V Superman
they also greenlit the new Batman
trilogy
originally there was just supposed to be
one Batman film but because the dailies
they were seeing from the set the studio
got so pumped that they're like hell
yeah let's do three Batman films so
Batman vs Superman has to completely
inform the direction that Batman's
character is going in Justice League
which is happening next they're going to
start shooting that in April and then
they'll start working on the first
Batman solo film obviously there's a
whole bunch of other Justice League solo
films that are happening we'll have a
Suicide Squad sequel eventually to a
most of Ben Affleck's energy after
Justice League will be devoted to
writing
and producing these new Batman films
there will probably be all kinds of
cameos from the Justice League
characters in everyone's different films
but mostly they'll be dedicated to each
single character and I know a lot of you
are wondering if they're gonna do a Red
Hood story line for the new Batman solo
trilogy I feel like that would be
awesome like if they followed up on this
death and the family look as he's
looking at this Robin suit we see Batman
chasing Joker and the Suicide Squad
trailer they have history together
that's gonna predate Batman V Superman
so it just makes sense that they would
do the Batman V Superman thing of taking
a lot of things from the comics a lot of
story elements and even if they changed
things about the Red Hood story arc they
would incorporate some of that into the
new trilogy but the one problem I see
with that is the idea of Resurrection we
don't know how fantastical the movie
universe is gonna be I mean we see the
Darkseid Omega symbol in the trailer
along with parademons so already that's
pretty fantastic so I guess resurrection
is just around the corner
and after Suicide Squad you also to
remember we have an interest in that
movie we'll have full-blown magic in
this universe I think they'll be able to
do any story that they wanted to do from
the comics the problem with the
Christopher Nolan Batman trilogy is that
it was very post superhero it wasn't
nearly as fantastical or comic book II
as the Marvel films were but I think for
Batman V Superman even though the tone
is a little bit darker
they definitely open it up story wise to
the idea of magic mysticism but it's
still grounded in reality so we're a
long ways off from Red Hood you know
they did do Robins would you want to see
any of them in the new Batman trilogy
based on what everyone behind the movie
has been saying it sounds like we're not
gonna see any Robins anytime soon except
in flashback like they have to address
this dead Robin but Batman as of Batman
V Superman seems like he's a long ways
off from taking on another partner that
is not Alfred we had that Justice League
teaser and I know everyone wants that
black costume to be Nightwing there's a
lot of people that think it's Green
Lantern I just I still think it's
something specific to the Holy Trinity
but because they do start shooting that
movie in April do not be surprised if
you see more flash Green Lantern
expanded Justice League character stuff
what's gonna happen next is the Deadpool
riders have been talking more about the
sequel more about x-force so I'll be
posting a Deadpool video tomorrow
morning be sure to subscribe to get that
if there's any Batman V Superman Suicide
Squad videos that you guys want me to do
just let me know in the comments
I think that take away from Ben Affleck
messing with all the Batman V Superman
script stuff is actually good the people
that worked on the script the stuff that
he would have been changing or writers
that people usually complain about so if
Ben Affleck is changing it he's probably
making it better but well he goes wait
for me to post that Deadpool video you
can click here for all my Batman V
Superman videos and you can click here
for my flash trailer for the next
episode thank you so much for watching
everybody let's high five I'll see you
guys tonight